they're looking at New Orleans home to
the oldest living American who served in
World War two this year we marked the
75th anniversary of d-day the Allied
invasion of Normandy that ultimately led
to Germany's surrender today fewer than
half a million American World War two
veterans who served in Europe the
Pacific and other places are still alive
CBS this morning Saturday co-host
Michelle Miller was just with the oldest
American vet as he celebrated his one
hundred and tenth birthday now Michelle
that's quite a party it was quite a
party and he is quite alive Lawrence
Brooks who was born on September 12 1909
and he I got to tell you is quite the
character he credits his good health
with long walks and chewing gum a habit
used to replace cigarettes when we
celebrated with him yesterday he learned
we learned that the super centenarian is
something of a local celebrity when you
bid on the planet as long as Lawrence
Brooks as you develop a following at a
hundred and ten he's the oldest American
World War two veteran a feat worthy of
pomp circumstance and a five star
serenade at the war's National Museum
what is the secret to your success
I love people I love people and people
love Lawrence Brooks that's why so many
of them showed up to celebrate even
strangers from 1941 to 1945 Brooks
served overseas with the predominantly
african-american 91st Engineer Battalion
in places like Australia and New Guinea
he was a reluctant soldier opting
instead to work as a cook in his unit
when I place what was drafted a new
yummy no sergeant was telling us ready
training so you can go kill people kill
people because I love people give me I
gotta go killer after returning home to
New Orleans
Brooks faced the challenge of the Jim
Crow South then more than a half-century
later
Hurricane Katrina threatened his life
and took his wife's cocaine coulda took
everything I owned one watch the weave
and everything and yet you survived that
too that's about there to the law that's
good to me works daughter Vanessa
credits her father's diet exercise and
faith for his long life and in some ways
it's prayer that made this celebration
possible I heard that he was an old
breath and I said
museum docent li crane met Brooks years
ago a church and helped launch the now
annual museum party in 2014 it's a
tradition employees hope won't end any
time soon we asked Brooks if this year
he enjoyed any birthday presence in
particular those ladies who left all
that red stuff on your face
Victor Bale you like all those kisses
yeah
[Music]
what an assignment right after the war
Lawrence Brooks worked as a forklift
operator and eventually retired at the
age of 70 that's already four decades
ago right he had five kids two of whom
he outlived thirteen grandchildren and
22 great-grandchildren I have to tell
you his daughter who's 60 years old
she's getting married in December whoa
promise to walk her down the aisle and
very coherent I mean I don't know what I
was expecting a hundred and ten yeah but
I wasn't expecting that he's very so
incredibly with a humor he actually says
his hearing is so good that people
yelled hear you fine I wanted to say
long live Lawrence Brooks but he's
already lived really long that's great
nice Thank You Michelle